the heading you should make is dangerous
we believe that yes there are three key
dangers some places will identify four I
think the four point is not really a
danger at all which kind of life is this
but you're going to explain it I'm happy
to do so for the first two days I'm
going to illustrate them and I'm not
going to go through the mechanics are
just get interest rate them with the
previous example x squared minus three
trying to find root three and evaluator
for my third danger I will have to
appeal to different functions you see
why shortly now reminding me rather than
bisection method what is the crucial
piece of knowledge the crucial skill
that new third method Newton's method
takes advantage of to be better uses
calculus it uses differentiation so
therefore even though that's a super
power just as a tip by the way you know
how we were doing route three before and
it's like the third approximation your
calculator couldn't tell the difference
right in general you know how it's about
um
decimal points of accuracy in general
every application of Newton's method we
double the number of all decimal places
you have accurate that's why I will like
only one point seventy five that's one
missile place then the next I was one
point seven three two that's three
decimal places the next one who's like
already 708 ok so it's incredible how
fast a Dutchman but differentiation is a
problem in fact there were three main
problems and they all have to do with
calculus pitches with geometric features
okay so first I'm going to illustrate
them and then we can give them names I
alluded to this one before danger number
one if you take X naught and if I have a
particular X naught such that the
tangent at X naught looks like that
what's the problem there's no next one
there will be no X 1 because this got
never intersects with the axis right so
the problem that causes there to be no X
1 X 1 is um some people call it what's a
horizontal tangent because that's what
it looks like but more geometrically
speaking though
is that X naught X naught is on a
stationary point that's the real issue
like you see how calculus is involved to
you if you choose X more poorly with
regard to the calculus G the geometric
features of the graph of the curve then
you're in trouble
next excellence on a stationary point
your stuff okay
stationary points can cause another
problem here comes from I'm going to try
to find roots three before I hope you
can see if I pick an x naught that say
is here suppose that is next what will
happen is I'll get my f of X naught I
will draw my tangent oops next month but
they look away x1 is you see where x1 is
where is it it's um it's golden yeah
he's int 1 right now I was trying to
find 3 3 what I'm doing is I am
converging to the wrong route I are you
spied one but I won't find the one that
I'm after okay now in the case of visit
opens oh just get negative of what I was
supposed to do but in the case is like a
cubic that looks like this and you're
trying to find this root okay
numerically this one like maybe you
can't tell without drawing of which one
is which so what would you call this
danger what would you name it I would
say you find the wrong route or you
approximate the wrong now that's what
happens but why does it happen
what does it have to do with the
calculus and geometric features at the
graph
think about it what was so bad about the
X naught that I chose I could say too
far away but you know what I could pick
an X naught that's really far away on
this side and it'll be fine
okay now the sign of the gradient that's
what some people identified is the wrong
problem the fourth problem brother
there's no real issue the real issue
that takes me there away is again the
stationary point that's the real culprit
right because I'm on the other side of
the stationary point right when I start
approximating I'm gonna approximate away
from the root I'm trying to find okay
because I want the gradient to take me
that way okay where is this table who's
gonna take me the other direction okay
sometimes when you're approximate you're
supposed to get a negative but so long
as you're on the right side you'll be
okay like if I wanted to find this route
the negative gradient is exactly what I
want
so negative ratings not a problem in
itself it's just that I'm not supposed
to get a negative from looking good this
way does that make sense so here X 1 was
a problem because on the stationary
point here if X naught is on the other
side of a stationary point you will
encounter just as a problem all right
now this one I'm deliberately not gonna
draw a picture yeah okay this time
I want us to just try it up and I'm just
gonna let X naught equal 1 okay now I
happen to know there is a route near
you've won okay it's quite close in fact
that you can probably look at this and
I've chosen it so easy so you might be
able to see what the route is but I want
you to watch the problems in emergence
okay I'm obviously gonna need F dash to
do this what is f dash
three and three x squared minus five
very good so now watch as I compute X 1
X 1 is equal to I'll just find out
because I rubbed it off this is the
formula and let's see what happens as I
another way
okay so X naught is 1 what's F of 1 it's
one takeaway five right so that's
negative 4 do you agree with that what's
F dash of one looks like 3 take away 5
which is negative 2 are you ok with that
yeah it looks good so that's one
takeaway 2 which is negative okay big
deal I'll just keep going I'll just do X
2 X 2 let's see what happens right X 2
is I'm going to go through this whole
person again but using negative 1 is my
next time it will be negative 1
takeaway okay what's F of negative 1 no
I think it's full right what's the
negatives because that's gonna be
negative and that's gonna be negative in
fact it's negative 1 plus 5 right so I
think I'm getting full yeah what's F
dash of negative 1
it's 3 take away 5 right yep so that's
minus 1 plus 2 right uh-oh I'm in
trouble ok so you can see something that
is going drastically wrong okay now take
a step back I said I chose an easy
function you guys know what this
function looks like right factorize it
for me won't have a look
you can take an X out and then you can
explain - fine you're gonna get root
five negative root five hundred five
right so this is a cubed it looks like
so this is what it looks like okay
now the root they every five it's like
two points two point something it's one
before I got into what it is so what
it's going to be somewhere around I'm
just gonna be on the stationing sorry
I'll do something like that okay now I
went down I found the tangent at that
point and it ended up sending me over
today there was my x1 and so I went
again and I said okay well let's have a
look let's find out what the tangent
will do and it sent me straight back to
my original value and it's like
Groundhog Day calculus okay what we call
this this is the name of day two number
three
it's called an oscillating sequence
because it goes back and forth and back
and forth and it never makes progress
okay that's what it is that's what it
looks like now can someone tell me just
like here in blue and here in food
what's the reason it does this and the
picture let me give you a tip it's not a
stationary point there is a symmetry to
this there's obviously a problem yeah
because all okay so all functions are a
problem but it's not just that it's an
odd function it's that right here at the
origin I have a point of inflection okay
now if I take those two together point
inflection and the fact that it's gone
what will happen is my gradients will
always be reverse of each other do you
see that right every single time so
they're always going to send you back
wherever you came from okay so really
what happened was there's a point of
inflection at the root we were trying to
approximate that was the problem okay
and that kind of screwed us up you could
also refer to the fact that it's a
function that's an issue too it's really
got the gradient effect in Canada so you
can see Newton's method really if you
know what you're doing with it but
because it relies on calculus it has
this kind of calculus Achilles heel if
you know careful with it right then
it'll send you down the garden path
where's the bisection method he doesn't
know anything about stationary points so
he's just gonna keep on going in a sort
of list directed way but much slower
that's why